thank you
[Music]
so uh 911 is coming up again right oh
yeah you guys got anything planned yeah
I'm Gonna Fly that day no joke I'm going
to Hawaii I'm flying that day too where
are you going Morocco dude I know a
bunch of people are flying out 9 11. I'm
flying I'm flying that day too jeez I'm
going from Sacramento back to Vegas is
that a way to honor 911 yeah I'm gonna
go fly that I'm like terrorists aren't
gonna [ __ ] prevent me from flying in
the sky do you think that like tickets
are discounted I thought it was gonna be
but no no no no no no they bump it up 10
on what I think it probably was like
right after like 9 12. but then like nah
yeah do you think the terrorists see a
plane in this guy and see our Defiance
on 911 and they're like damn it they're
still flying
I feel like they look at that and then
they go oh we failed
did they
yeah they look at it and they go that
was the main goal yeah they don't want
to appear to I don't think they want to
put a speed
but front of a country they want to like
wreck the country they're probably like
they're like oh I bet they're watching
Minions on that plane [ __ ] them yeah
yeah you know
regardless of 9 11 it's almost the 13th
of September yeah that's the bigger date
yeah it's at my house like I'll bring it
back it belongs in this room it belongs
in this room so the reason I'm saying
that is because uh there was almost a
mini 911 that happened oh my God what's
considered a mini 911 it's more like an
8-10 this dude hijacked a like a small
plane and then he started circling it in
uh Mississippi and he called 9-1-1 yeah
and he threatened to crash it into the
Walmart
what hey [ __ ] the Walmart in Mississippi
that's a big deal yeah that's so good
that sounds like a redneck 911. that's
not yeah that's not even a mini 911
that's a medium 911 yeah that's like do
it I feel like if I was the cops and I'm
probably irresponsible I'd like no
worries I just shoot his ass out the sky
or you're like how'd you get signal up
there that's what I would want was he
like what's your character yeah are you
T-Mobile you give me a million dollars
I'm crashing this thing into the Super
Walmart
was that yeah was there a ransom no he
didn't have a there was nothing he
wanted he was just like a crazy dude
threatening to do it here's his flight
path that he took while he was circling
that looks [ __ ] up oh wait oh this is
like when you give like spiders drugs
she looks like taika's art dude is that
a [ __ ] you wait there's something
written there like a middle finger it
says 911 is an inside job
it says Bush did not love him he was
trying to yeah say a message in there
what I picture is you know those like
single planes are like those propeller
planes they're like those farm crop
dusters they look weak as hell right so
I picture this [ __ ] hitting Walmart and
then just [ __ ] breaking apart or like
like falling down like probably it's a
[ __ ] look like this remote control
plane not let's not unless it hits the
garden section of Walmart you know what
I'm saying [ __ ] that [ __ ] up then you're
good yeah yeah how easy is it to hijack
a plane he let he had a post on his
Facebook saying like I'm sorry area
never meant to hurt anyone like as if he
like there was like that also means he
knows how to fly yeah like he has his
license and [ __ ] he saw so many
influencers like trolling in Walmart
that he was like I'm a one-up that it's
just a prank yeah I'm not gonna moan in
your ear I'm going to crash a plane and
do it oh those type of they they bother
me they bother me well they take [ __ ]
and they just Chuck it on another oh I
like that one I like the one where
they're licking all the ice cream and
put it back I love that [ __ ]
it's the worst I think they should be
shot on the spot if someone was doing
that to you at Walmart like trolling
yeah I think about that I think about if
I'm gonna be on that end if they're
gonna like hit me with the hit I don't
know I hate the ear Motors like when I
see them especially pick on like older
people it's man it makes me want to oh I
was laughing I was like that's so good
shut the [ __ ] up when you look at the
elaborate nature of his [ __ ] that must
make you like cringe on you I cry
laughing well there's a difference it's
like there's like 18 levels of depth of
thought that he was like okay The Human
Experience is so [ __ ] up that if I put
him in this position they're gonna think
this then I'm gonna do this then I'm
gonna do this that that's like
forethought but when you just moan in
your ear and that's like the whole punch
line well their thought is like oh look
at this old man or old woman they're not
gonna do [ __ ] yeah that's what sucks
about it yeah they're like hey remember
sex
you know what I do like though is when
they throw the ball at them yeah and
then they're like opening up a book oh
and then they're like what happened and
then more balls come because their
friends are on the other aisles genius
yeah I like the ones where the guys
knock down all the stuff on the racks I
love it dude that's my favorite and
still open up a book oh I love that part
that's my favorite part hey can you eat
it out clean it up oops there's this
yeah how do they all have [ __ ] like
flour dough or some [ __ ] or like baking
soda and they just Chuck it at somebody
dude I go to Home Depot all the time and
I never see girls like in bikinis there
is that one of the things that they do a
big thing it's either a grocery store a
grocery store or Home Depot there's
always naked girls I saw this one where
girls wearing [ __ ] orange bikini
would like it will look like a Home
Depot outfit and she was trying to help
people oh no it wasn't a Hooters outfit
no way send me that one I'll send you
send me that one and then and then
they're just like you work here and she
goes yeah you want some help and her
titties was all jiggling and [ __ ] damn
yeah it's really cool the next day Joe
was at Home Depot for the whole weekend
dude but I couldn't find anybody
searching I went to Home Depot in
Honolulu LA and [ __ ] Las Vegas didn't
see one you gotta go to the pipeline the
pipe aisle
I'm in the wrong one
as someone that like knows how to throw
a punch you don't have that reflex if
like someone moaned in your ear do you
like is that no no I'm not really no no
no I would I would I would immediately
catch what's going on I'd probably do it
back I'd probably just like troll back
and hit him with a harder eye
more like on him back like the
communication yeah the communication
yeah communication style yeah he hits me
with it like on I'm like I'm like [ __ ]
yeah we're just gonna yes and we're just
out [ __ ] we're just [ __ ] in the
aisles
where they regret doing it at all oh
that's is that what you do that's what I
would do yeah I like it when the guys
are like damn baby look at those bums
and then and the girls are like
[Music]
what did you say and then a girl pops
out with
ah yeah they're right behind them so the
couple with the couple like nice melons
and then the the somewhere behind them
with them and then the guy's like what'd
you say about my girl
this is one of those models where we're
like kind of talking [ __ ] but then now
after it I'm like building a
relationship with all this type of
content that I'm gonna enjoy watching it
later if I if this pops up on my feed
I'll kill myself all of them but the
fact that we're it's like the fact that
we can remember and talk about it I'm
like damn it's actually kind of good and
I go what the [ __ ] and then I look at
the [ __ ] views and it's like 20
million I'm like what the [ __ ] I think
there's I think there's a there's
definitely I'm low-key I'm kind of
jealous that I I I'm not I'm not gonna
do that I'm not gonna do that I could
never it's too it's too too much success
too too much wealth it gets generated
I'll report it as terrorism there is one
that I do enjoy and it's it it's a it's
the one at the gym where there's only
like two guys at the gym and then
somebody will like well a guy's working
out with his headphone they'll take like
a garbage bag and throw the whole thing
over him and then while he's struggling
to take it off he put the other guy puts
one on himself and he's sitting there
too and he's like that's kind of that's
kind of time that's [ __ ] when they do
it to it themselves yeah that's right
out of all your years of doing these
like videos in your like early Channel
nobody ever counter [ __ ]
counter-attacked any of your uh there
was one guy during one of my Bangbus
pranks who he was going along with it
like in a way where he obviously figured
it out and I had to like basically I was
like obviously did this video go up yeah
yeah we put it up that's the the one
where he's like yeah the guy who
actually took his like pants off and
everything no that wasn't different that
was a real one Steve called him a small
dick guy and he's yelling this is the
guy who yeah he shows up in the
beginning and then I asked I'm like oh
you're the big dick guy and then he's
like oh I don't know and then I look at
my producer I'm like I thought we got a
big dick guy we got a [ __ ] little
dick guy here and I started screaming at
my producer about how this guy's dick is
little and how we need big dick guys we
can't have this like I'm gonna get fired
we're all gonna get fired and like we
need big [ __ ] on this set
and yet I pulled my producer in the back
and so he could you can still hear all
this through the glass and so I'm like
screaming about how this guy's got a
little tiny dick and how we're not gonna
be able to satisfy the women and they're
all and everyone's Gonna Know
like
and then the best is when he comes out
he's like all right you ready to go come
on let's go
after I basically fired one of my
producers I'm like you're [ __ ] fired
get the [ __ ] out of here is your
producer an actor too like how do they
keep it in no they well they were kind
of busting up but we were behind glass
oh okay okay so I I was just screaming
and [ __ ] biting his head off but
we're behind glass so yeah and this is
this guy figured it out that it was that
was I think no what happened was once he
saw he said once he saw Robert Rex he
remembered the Bangbus prank videos I
don't think he recognized me because I
had a different look but he Robert
Robert looks like a 1970s porn star with
the [ __ ] mustache and [ __ ] oh and
like she's like wearing this leotard
she's one of the porn star guys he's
iconic when you look at that guy you'll
have a lot of work yeah he does a lot of
work so but I think he I think the
Bangbus pranks have already been viral
enough at that point where he saw Robert
that's what he told us afterwards he
said he saw Robert does that happen
often where you're you're doing you're
running a prank and they kind of they
already know who you are but that would
happen yeah yeah eventually when I was
in Venice Beach that would start to
happen yeah when I was doing my art
trolling especially that's when people
would just come up and go hey dude I
know what you're doing that's [ __ ]
awesome dude and you lose content you
can't post that right or do you uh we
could post somebody in the video who's
just saying that to me real quick like
on the interstitial because it's not
like I'm stuck with the same person the
whole time we were cycling people in and
out of it yeah I would just stand there
and just try to get I'm like hey who
wants a free caricature 100 free and
then people would come up and actually
try to get free art and I'm like hey I'm
recording this from my [ __ ] local
like college class my teacher's breaking
my balls about how I have to film myself
doing this [ __ ] because they don't
believe I'm actually showing up the
class and doing all my stuff so whatever
yo so do the fake pranks bother you yeah
they do but they're obviously they do
but it's far like especially back then
because I was like in the middle of the
war basically like like fighting on the
middle of the world yeah because it's
like you know it's the real prankers
versus the fake prankers and the fake
pranks just ruined everything yeah they
did man and they were doing some stupid
ass [ __ ] going into like going into like
South Central control and like [ __ ]
with nice people and like like doing
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and like like pretend
like they're pulling guns on people and
stuff yeah dude that was a thing for a
while they're like doing pranks in the
hood yeah and they just mess with people
almost get punched in the [ __ ] head
that [ __ ] was so bad it was and it was
so bad too it was just it was bad for
everybody it was bad too so I hated all
that but that's why I liked your stuff
because it was like almost in response
to that [ __ ] directly and it still
smashed like the [ __ ] what like when
you started making fun of pranks gone
sexual that was the end-all because
remember that everybody would do these
pranks it would say gone sexual to like
get clicks and then he did sexual prank
gone sexual I did sex in public prank
gone sexual that was the [ __ ] man
and I would just walk up the chicks and
be like hey you want to [ __ ] and they're
like yeah sure and then because they
were just actors we we totally staged
that one right because that was the joke
joke was on the audience joke was on the
people who watched that [ __ ] okay okay
so yeah I just walk up to these these
chicks and we're all wearing nude
underwear and I'm like I'm like hey
what's up you wanna [ __ ] and she's like
yeah sure and then like we immediately
started talking close and that and then
and then like she would like I would
Mount her and I'd be like yeah
that video was like 200 million views or
something dude it still gets comments to
this day
[Music]